mosquitoes don't go through customs
syke is a real threat for Los Angeles
County and our residents in areas where
the invasive 80s is present so what
we're doing right now we're really doing
outreach to our residents we're doing
controlled backyard to backyard trying
to eliminate breeding sources this is
not something where we can build a wall
to prevent mosquitoes don't go through
customs to the extent that we're not
handling this thing on the front end
we're going to have bigger problems on
the back
if I'm a young family right now or
somebody who's thinking about starting a
family this is just a piece of insurance
that I want to purchase